what are you doing to keep yourself
healthy and to be able to have these
conversations so that you can speak
clearly with you know without that
clarity that you got you know there's
probably a lot more than I could do in
terms of self-care and keeping myself
taking care of myself mentally and and
emotionally and spiritually but the big
piece of it is I'm so excited I don't
want to sit down and take a break
because I feel like we're really at a
moment of great change where so many
more people are talking about this are
active or engaged in these conversations
inclusion in a different way than I've
ever seen in my lifetime how surprised
have you been with people wanting to
engage and people being ready for change
what I've been singing in videos of
people protesting for black lives matter
and it being all types of people all
walks of life all races all genders all
sexualities walking together not only in
one place but then obviously around the
world seeing that it made me say wow
these people were ready people were
reacting to this as though they were
ready to engage and I think that's
what's happened you talk a lot about
black trans lives matter and you've been
calling people out and in the queer
community for maybe not speaking up
people's reactions to all this reflect
their relationship to empathy I believe
that I'm a considerate person and I
understand that everyone can't move at
the same pace anyone who is queer
probably understands some of that if
you've ever had to come out to someone
certainly people who are trans have had
to at least myself as a trans person
have experienced having to sort of
police myself and shift my mode and
speed to accommodate other people being
able to catch up with pronouns name
changes so I'm a pretty chill person
when it comes to you being able to catch
up but what is not acceptable for me is
for us to sit around and react
nonchalantly when there's obvious crimes
against humanity I don't care who you
are what color you are what gender you
are what sexual
most of the people that I've called out
or engaged with and I haven't dragged
anyone like you know by name I've just
called out their behavior and described
to their behavior and their reaction and
if that makes them uncomfortable then so
be it
your discomfort does not is not more
important than the lives of people being
killed when you see people turn a corner
does that give you hope absolutely
because it's useful it is powerful for
you to just tweet in this instance black
lives matter out loud publicly say trans
lives matter or that you believe in
LGBTQIA equality and you're allowing
some of your followers who you may not
even know that identify in that way
you're telling them that you see them
right now is the time to do it if you're
interested at all and completely
overturning racism now is the time to do
it when are you running for office
[Laughter]